uh hello everyone welcome back to the
afternoon session
so this is the last tutorial talk of the
boot camp week
so in this castle we are lucky to have
professor peter glenn
from stanford university the department
of management science and engineering
so we know like in rl so we always try
to estimate
some sort of conditional expectations or
estimate policy gradients so we need
estimation and
simulation like basically in every
single aspect of rl
and professor peter guillen is going to
teach us
the basics of simulation and we'll learn
like how to
potentially leverage techniques from
simulation and multi-color methods
to be useful in reinforcement learning
it is all yours thank you mindy
i'd like to thank the organizers for
this opportunity to speak as part of the
rl boot camp
i want to start by saying that my
intention here is to give a broad
overview in these talks
some of the tools are available from
within the simulation literature
so as such i'm not going to be focusing
on rl applications per se
the intention really is going to be to
give a quick guided tour of some
relevant research areas
and let you think about the potential
implications for the irl community
so
the outline for the first talk is going
to be that i'll
talk about the basics of simulation aka
also known as the monocarlo method
uh i'll talk about output analysis that
really
relates to the question of how many
samples do you need to take
in order to have a reliable estimate
of the expectation or probability to be
computed
and then in the second talk this
afternoon i'm going to talk about what
is known within the simulation
literature is
variance reduction and i'll also talk
about
gradient estimation and a bit about
stochastic optimization
so that's the basic outline of the two
talks
so let me start with some basic
terminology
so where does the word simulation come
from comes from
exactly the mathematical sciences view
of
the word simulation simulation is
typically used to talk about
a generation of trajectories of
dynamical systems
a very simple class of dynamical systems
are the deterministic dynamical systems
that go with so-called
autonomous dynamical systems in the
discrete time context
we would have the state of the system at
time n plus one
is some function of the state at time n
g could be linear or non-linear
and of course the continuous time
version of that would be the
differential equation d by dt of x of t
the derivative of x of t
equal to some function of x of t
so in the world of stochastics and we
think about
simulations many of the simulations that
one does
are simulations of corresponding
stochastic dynamical systems
in which now the deterministic
recursion that i described
up at the top of this slide is replaced
by a stochastic recursion
in which x m plus one the state of time
n plus one
is some function of the state of time n
and some u independent noise
that i'll describe as c n plus one
of course we all know that this sort of
stochastic dynamical system
corresponds to a markov chain and if the
cns are iid
then i get a markov chain with
stationary transition probabilities
that's basically the plain vanilla type
of markov chain that we're most familiar
with
then of course a continuous time variant
of this would be
a dynamical system in which dx by dt
is equal to mu of x of t and that is
perturbed by some white noise or random
noise cross x of t
and this roughly speaking is uh
corresponding to the world of markov
diffusions or solutions of stochastic
differential equations
so that is basically a continuous time
version of a markov chain
so in any case simulation is all about
simulating trajectories of dynamical
systems whether it be deterministic
risky caster now one of the key
uh important points to recognize
in looking at
simulation in particular stochastic
simulation is its connection to the
world of numerical integration
so in particular if we're interested in
computing some
expected value of a performance measure
w some random variable w where w let's
say is some function of the trajectory
of a markov chain
x i i ranging from zero up to
some random time horizon capital t
of course uh the whole principle of
stochastic
estimate simulation expected value by
running independent computer experiments
in the world of simulation these will be
called
replications if we run n iid
replications w one w two of w
up to w and let's say the random
variable w so do
n independent computer experiments and
then estimate
uh the quantity of interest the expected
value
as the average of the
uh wi's obtained from these different
independent
simulations so this is the basis of the
so-called monte carlo method i'll come
back to that a bit later
now as i was suggesting a moment ago
if the x i's come from a markov chain
then of course
we can write down the state of the
system in terms of the
noise sequence c1 through
c d if we have a time horizon
d and that means that the expected value
of the random variable w that we're
interested in uh we're assuming now that
that is some function of the state
trajectory
up to the time horizon d and
that in turn can be
in terms of the noise sequence c1
through cb
and of course that can be represented as
a multiple integral uh given that the
ci's
are independent of one another so the h
i of z is here are the
let's say the probability density
functions of c i's
and we're integrating the function f
tilde
relative to those uh
that joint density so a key point
in thinking about simulation and
thinking about monitoring general is
that
uh expectations can always if we wish be
viewed as
uh integrals potentially over some high
dimensional space
you can see in this context that the uh
dimension of the integration that we're
doing corresponds to the
length of the time horizon of course it
could easily be that the simulation
uh involves a markov chain in which the
ci's are most naturally vector valued
so if the ci's take values in
rk then effectively these h i of z
i's corresponds to probability density
functions on k space
and then we're doing a k times d uh
dimensional integral
so in the world of simulation it would
typically be the case almost invariably
be the case that this
integration that we're effectively
trying to do is
very high dimensional
so conversely if we have
a
an integral that can be expressed as a
integration over d dimensional space
i can if i wish just multiply and divide
through by the
product of a bunch of
probability density functions in which
case
i can recognize
that uh by multiplying dividing through
by this product
uh i can now recognize that this
quantity here
is being integrated against a joint
probability density function on rd
and as a consequence i can write this
quantity alpha
as an expected value involving the
uh integrand that
we are left with and particularly
involving
the expected value of q of z1 through zd
divided by the product of the h i of z
i's where the z i's have corresponding
probability density function
h sub i so an important
fact to recognize is not only can
every expected value effectively be
written as a
high dimensional integral but every uh
integral can also effectively be written
as an expectation so there's
essentially a one-to-one correspondence
between
computing expected values and computing
uh
high dimensional limit rules
so uh simulation is all about using
sampling based methods to compute
expected values
expected values are in turn
high dimensional integrals if we choose
to
view them this way and as a consequence
simulation is really a class of methods
based on sampling
that is intended to compute high
dimensional integrals
this is a method that got its name back
in the second world war from
uh stanislaus named this method after
the
monte carlo method he was a physicist
that was involved with the
manhattan project and uh monte carlo of
course
is evocative of the world of gambling
and casinos and so forth monte carlo
being a very famous casino that existed
at that time and still exists
to this day along the mediterranean
so
from the standpoint of reading the
scientific literature on simulation it's
important to recognize
that when we talk about stochastic
simulation we're effectively talking
about demonic parallel method
so when you look into the literature for
references to this general area you may
oftentimes want to search under the
terminology monica law
so we've already alluded to
the monte carlo method again the basic
problem of interest is that we want to
compute some expected value
of a random variable w and the basic
idea is to generate
iid replications to run independent
computer simulations w one w
two w n through w of
the uh random variable w and then to
form
an estimator corresponding to the sample
mean
so alpha n here's just the average of
the w
i's and of course
one question that we would ask
scientifically mathematically
is why is this a reasonable method of
course reasonable should mean that the
method converges as the number of
computer experiments and number of
replications and goes to infinity
and of course that's guaranteed by the
law of large numbers
if the w i's or ids we're assuming here
then the strong law of large numbers
guarantees that if w's integrable
alpha n converges as the sample size of
n goes to infinity to the quantity that
we're trying to compute
the more interesting question is how
fast does it converge
and that's a question that's answered
from the
central limit theorem so central limit
theorem of course asserts that if we
have
random variables with uh
finite variance
uh they uh
and we scale the difference between the
estimator of interest and the quantity
we're trying to compute
by square root of n then that scale
difference converges to
a normal random verb both mean zero and
varying sigma squared
so that's a statement to the standard uh
plain vanilla
central limit theorem and of course
uh if i unpack this
uh weak convergence statement so this is
a statement in which the double arrow
corresponds to
weak convergence or
what's also equivalently known as
convergence and distribution
uh if we unpack this then we see that
our estimator of interest
alpha n is exactly the quantity we're
trying to compute
alpha plus an error term and the error
term looks approximately like a normal
random variable
with mean zero and standard deviation
sigma over root n
and that has some profound implications
uh the fact that the
error takes this particular form
implication number one is that the
convergence rate
is slow so in particular
if i want to compute alpha to let's say
an additional
significant figure of accuracy from what
uh
i might have currently with a given
sample size n
we can ask the question how much larger
do we need to make the sample size to
add an additional significant figure of
accuracy
and of course that means multiplying the
current accuracy by
a factor of 10 in other words reducing
the error by a factor of 10.
we see because of square root uh in the
denominator that it's a consequence we
need to make and larger by a factor of a
hundred
so every additional significant figure
involves multiplying
the sample size by a factor of 100.
monocarlo ie simulation
is not a scientific computing method
that
is interesting to use in problems where
you want
high accuracy answers but it may be
perfectly suitable
in settings where you're quite satisfied
with let's say three significant figures
of accuracy
unfortunately in the great majority of
applications that
many of us are interested in we already
have significant
model here in the uh
specification of the underlying
stochastic model the underlying
stochastic model doesn't perfectly
represent the real world and
so the idea of looking for 10
significant figure accuracy in a context
where the model error is already
significant
doesn't really make much sense to reduce
significant figures is often just fine
and so uh living with that
relative inaccuracy of the monte carlo
method
is uh quite reasonable under
the circumstances another thing that we
can see is that the
underlying dimensionality of the
random variables that we're sampling the
z's or the w's that we're sampling
um doesn't come into this uh convergence
rate analysis
so independent of the dimension the
ambient dimension in which the zi's or
wi's are sitting
the convergence rate is always well over
square root that's something i'll come
back
to in a bit
another very nice characteristic of this
uh
central limit theorem result is that
uh the magnitude of the error of alpha
n is an estimator of alpha depends on
the underlying problem instance the
underlying distribution of the
zi's or w i's only through a single
constant
namely the standard deviation of a
random variable
so this is a particularly
nice scientific computing context in the
sense that the problem hardness
is effectively characterized by a single
constant namely the standard deviation
so if you can make the standard
deviation smaller you get a more
efficient
algorithm if the standard deviation is
big uh
the problem uh is the expected guy is
going to be hard to compute
and finally the fact that the
convergence rate
is as slow as this means that error
assessment is going to be important
we can't just take the view that if we
make the sample size
and large that we can uh
reasonably expect that alpha and is
necessarily going to be close to alpha
so as a consequence uh we're going to
want to do
error assessment of some kind we're
going to want to be able to ask a
question
can we scientifically take the view that
the sample size
and that we've uh utilized is large
enough
to have computed alpha for a reasonable
level of accuracy
so that error assessment in the world of
simulation world of modifier was
typically going to
enabled through a confidence interval
so most of this first lecture
is going to be about different ways of
constructing
confidence and of course
so uh in particular the central limit
term that i just described
uh if you rewrite that central limiter
it basically can be
rewritten to assert
that this random interval centered at
the estimator alpha done
so in other words alpha n plus or minus
something
is going to be asymptotically as a
sample size n goes to infinity
a 100 times one minus delta percent
confidence interval so if
we're searching for a 90 continuous
delta would be 0.1
we would select z values from the normal
distribution so the probability that
normal zero one is graphically minus z
and plus v
is ninety percent and then having
calibrated uh
the z value in that way this random
interval
will cover the uh true
expected value roughly 90 of the time
if n is large
of course the procedure that i just
described is not
practically implementable because
uh in general we don't know the standard
deviation sigma this whole
simulation is being undertaken in order
to compute the
expected value of the random variable uh
let's say w
uh we don't know the expected value of w
we're certainly not going to know the
standard deviation of w
so uh the confidence interval that i
just described
is not an implementable confidence
interval but again one of the
beautiful things about monica and
beautiful things about simulation
is that while we don't know sigma
it can be easily estimated from the
sample itself so internally from the
sample
we can just uh estimate sigma squared
estimate the variance
through the so-called sample variance
and
here's the sample variance down here
this is how it's defined in the iid
setting and it's not hard to show that
if you plug in a sample estimate for
sigma
then when the sample size n is large
given that
the sample variance converges almost
surely to sigma squared as
n goes to infinity uh one can conclude
that the confidence interval procedure
that one
obtains by substituting the sample
standard deviation
for the true standard deviation again
has the property that
it's an approximate uh let's say 90
percent confidence interval when
uh delta is equal to 0.1
so let me
say a little bit more about this
confidence statement
so this constant statement relies on the
central limit theorem
and the nature of this confidence
statement is that it's asymptotic in the
sample size
n there's a guarantee for any
finite variance distribution
that if we look at the
probability that the expected value of
interest is trapped inside this random
interval that can be computed from the
samples obtained through running and
independent computer experiments
at random uh interval
that just takes the form alpha and plus
or minus something
where something is given by a z value
from the normal table
times that's n over root n
when we construct a confidence interval
in this way we have a guarantee from the
laws of
probability that the probability that
that random interval covers
the true parameter alpha converges to
the specified probability
as the sample size of n goes to infinity
and of course
one of the things that we see in this
statement is that there's no guarantee
for any fixed sample size
n now uh
in some areas of computational science
and many areas of computer science in
particular people like having
uh hard guarantees for fixed sample size
again
and of course uh that's something that
is quite easy to do in some settings in
particular
one way of potentially getting a hard
error down that you can use for
fixed sample sizes and is to apply
chebychev's inequality that he shows
inequality in this context
translates into the statement that
the probability of the true parameter
alpha
lies in the interval alpha n minus
epsilon over root n to alpha n plus
epsilon or root n
that has that has to be greater than or
equal to one minus c square over epsilon
squared
provided that c squared is a
bound on the uh variance
of w and of course that's guaranteed
if we know that w uh is a bounded random
variable
in particular if we take c as the down
down the random variable w
then we have a hard air build so
uh this is a quite satisfying result um
in the sense that we have a finite
sample size
and guarantee um
however um
there are a couple of uh problems with
this
down from a fractal standpoint number
one is that
uh many of the random verbal probably
most of the random variables that one
uh encounters in practice are not
bounded random variables
and uh to actually a priori bound the
variance of a random variable
uh in a given simulation environment or
a given
computational environment might be quite
challenging it might be
that it almost exceeds one's
mathematical abilities
to pull that off but even if one can
pull that off it's pretty likely that
the variance bound that you'll get would
be extremely
weak bound and then if you were to plug
that into chebyshev
you'd get probably something that would
be effectively unusable
from a practical standpoint so
um the the
basic challenge with using uh chebyshev
style arguments are almost in fact
pretty much all of the hard error bounds
that one sees in the world of sampling
based algorithms
are based on assumptions of the random
variables
that are being sampled
have known bounds on their support and
one class of random variables that has
exactly that characteristic
actually do come up widely in practice
of course our gradually random variable
zero one valued random variables
but outside of that class of simple
uh such quantities um
the types of downs that one would get
tend to be very very loose and that
sort of needs blood for the practical
standpoint in the direction
of using uh
asymptotic validity to theoretically
justify the algorithms that one
uses it's probably also the case to some
degree that
part of why asymptotic validity plays
such a big role
in the simulation theory of literature
and the monte carlo theory literature is
that
uh many of the people that have
worked in the area were brought up so to
speak
within the statistics and probability
worlds
and in that context in those communities
asymptotically valid
results are the standard bread and
butter of
those communities from particular
proving limit theorems and
involving weak convergence or various
other types of results
is the standard theoretical mode of uh
analysis and so to some extent it's a
cultural issue that relates to
the uh focus on asymptotic validity
rather than hardware advanced
i think there also is a practical issue
that
hard error downs in general would
probably be close to unusable
in many practical instances even if you
could compute a hard error
estimator
okay so let me just say a little bit
more about this dimensional
insensitivity that i
discussed earlier so uh we
talked about the fact that uh when you
are
computing expected value that it
typically can be
represented as a high dimensional
integration problem
and um it's worth recognizing
that of course high dimensional
integration problems there are
all kinds there's a very large
literature on
quadrature rules and various other
things involving deterministic
integration rules so
these determination integration rules
typically involve a
specification of various points and
let's say the d-dimensional hypercube
where you would evaluate the function of
interest and then you might weight the
function evaluations of these different
points in some
way that would correspond to a weighted
integration rule
and it's well known that if you look at
the worst case
error across reasonably behaved
functions
the reasonably behaved functions in this
case would be
functions that are r times continuously
differentiable with bounds on the
various derivatives that they
rate of convergence in the computational
budget c tends to degrade significantly
as a function of the dimension d in
which the random variables are sitting
so in particular we see that the
exponent up here has a one over d in it
that of course is the cursing
dimensionality that we
often hear about in various areas of
computational
mathematics we do see
that we get some gain from smoothness
the more derivatives we have
we get faster convergence the most
important
point in this result is the fact that
you get
uh extremely serious degradation
in the rate of convergence when d gets
large
all right so that's what happens if you
apply deterministic integration rules
things based on quadrature type ideas
what about if you apply monte carlo
well again as i was hinting at a moment
ago
we can apply chebyshev in this context
and chebyshev
says that we can
bound the probability that the monte
carlo estimate deviates from the true
quantity of interest
by some quantity of scaled according to
square root as
let's say epsilon over root n that can
be bounded by k squared over f squared
with k is a bound on the magnitude of f
tilde
and of course uh
given a computational budget c the
number of
uh uniform random variables
that you can generate in a computational
budget c is going to be scaling in
proportion to c
but uh the number of d tuples number of
uniform d tuples that you can compute
obviously scales downwards by a factor
one over d
so the sample size the total number of d
doubles that we can generate
in computational budget c d grades is
uh c over d as a function of the
dimension
d and so there is some
uh dimensional dependence in this result
but it's a very modest dimensional
dependence uh
involving this square root so
it's fair to say i think based on this
analysis that monica parallel tends to
be quite
insensitive to dimension
much less sensitive than this result is
suggesting where you have a
one over d in the exponent
now i'd be remiss if i didn't uh mention
to you
that there's a another alternative
integration technology that
one can apply called quasi-random
sequences quasi-random
the use of the term random is a bit of a
misnomer in the sense that
these sequences are actually
deterministic sequences that are
intended to be deterministic
uh the fundamental structure of these
sequences is such that they are chosen
to satisfy a so-called equidistribution
property that means that if you look at
the fraction
of these ui so ui here now being a point
in d
space the fraction of the uis let's
imagine that v
is equal to two so here's a unit square
in
dimension two and here's let's say an
a an a point that corresponds to an a1
a2 and then we want the fraction of
points
the fraction of u y's that fall into
this little
sub-rectangle to converge as the sample
size
n is a number of the chosen points n
goes to infinity
to the area of the sub-rectangle which
of course is just
a1 times a2 so the d-dimensional case
when b
is greater than or equal to two we want
the fraction of u y's falling to that
subred
sub uh hyper rectangle
to be given by the volume of that sound
have a hyper rectangle which is
just the product of the ais so it turns
out that there are these
equally distributed sequences that have
the property that uh
if i soup over all such a's
the uh maximal deviation between this
uh the fraction of points in such an a
hyper rectangle versus the volume is
going to
zero at rate log n to the d power
divided by
m and that turns out that for certain
class of
integrands integrands that are
have finite party grouse variation
that the corresponding integration error
also goes to zero at rate log n to the d
power divided by m and of course this is
a
faster convergence rate in general than
one over square root of n
so now i should mention
that uh we have a log in here you could
take the view that
i think we often do that log in is
almost
uh of order one and just disregard the
presence of that login
but uh you can see that when d is large
let's imagine d is of the order of 100
and you have log n raised to the 100th
power
that number actually can be quite large
and as a consequence when d is very big
uh you do get some uh it is the case
that that this error bound uh suggests
that this class of algorithms degrades
to some degree and as a consequence with
d is very very big
uh i think it's still the case today
that people view a monocarlo based
algorithms in which we use
purely random numbers to do our
integration
as being a better class of uh
integration methods
than uh what one gets through
quasi-random sequences
the quasi-random sequences do uh uh have
a good record
for uh doing uh for successfully
integrating
integrants that have this finite hearty
cause variation
um it's basically a generalization of
bounded variation in one dimension to
the d dimensional case
and uh in dimensions let's say
up to order 50 some people would claim
even higher than that these types of uh
methods
can work very well and can successfully
integrate
with lower error air monte carlo
in many contents so good to be aware of
this
basic approach
okay so
now let's switch to the uh
topic that will consume the rest of this
uh lecture which is
output analysis namely uh
given that we have a simulation based
algorithm for computing some parameter
alpha how long do we need to run the
simulation or to get a required accuracy
that's the
whole question underlying the area of
output analysis
so one thing to recognize again from a
terminology standpoint
is if you want to compute an expected
value
and let's suppose that we're in a
setting where the random variable w is
simulatable so we can
simulate iid copies w1w2 of
the wn and then just estimate uh the
alpha expected value through the sample
mean in this setting are really two
types of procedures
so called fixed sample size procedures
where we choose a priori the sample size
n and then at the end we construct a
confidence interval that
in general is of unknown size a priori
so after you've run the fixed sample
size procedure
it could be that you've got a big
confidence interval it could be that
you've got a small kind of control
you're not quite sure
before you run the procedure as to what
the size of that confidence
interval would be that's a fixed sample
size procedure
now from a scientific computing
standpoint it's often the case that we
prefer to
set the precision or tolerance
first that corresponds to the world of
so-called sequential procedures
so in a sequential procedure which first
choose the error tolerance epsilon and
what does
epsilon basically correspond to here it
corresponds to the
width of the confidence interval we
decide apriori i want the constant
variable to be
let's say plus or minus 0.1
and now we're going to generate samples
until the confidence interval
has that required size and it turns out
that uh at least as epsilon goes to zero
that there
are many different types of results that
suggest that
these types of procedures are
asymptotically valid because epsilon
goes to zero
and the first of these results was is
due to challenge robbins in 1965 and
there's been quite a bit of follow-on
work since that time
so in the remainder of this lecture i'm
going to
focus exclusively on fixed sample size
procedures but
for virtually everything that i will
talk about there would be a
sequential analog to this output
analysis method
so the very first setting that we
described was the setting of iid
replications
now we're going to talk about smooth
functions of expectations that's the
second setting in which
a more complicated setting in which one
option wants to do output analysis
so in this context the parameter of
interest
is some smooth function of a vector of
expectation so imagine z
as being rd value
the natural estimator of course is just
to uh
use a plug-in estimator just estimate
expected value of z
through the sample average of the random
vectors
z bar n and then to plug z bar n
into the g function and that then will
be our estimator
alpha n and uh
now to analyze the large sample behavior
of
alpha n we recognize that z bar n is
going to be close to the expected value
of z
and if g is smooth we can do a taylor
expansion of
g of z bar n around g of expected value
of z
and then of course we get this is the
first order term in the taylor expansion
of course the central limit theorem says
that z bar n minus expected value should
be of order
one over root n and it turns out that
the second quarter terms in this taylor
expansion
will involve uh terms roughly of the
square of this
deviation that's just a consequence of
taylor expanding
and of course that means that uh since z
bar n minus the expected values of order
one over n all those additional terms
will be small
relative n in other words middle of
one over square root of the sample size
so that suggests that uh
alpha n minus alpha basically is largely
explained
by this piece and of course this piece
is just a deterministic gradient
multiplied by a mean
0 random variable and now the central
limit theorem
applies exactly to the analysis of such
quantities
and as a consequence we uh
can uh observe that
we have a central limit theorem going
before alpha n in particular
square root of n times alpha n minus
alpha divided by an appropriate estimate
of the standard deviation
sigma rising the central limit theorem
that
normalized so-called pivotal quantity
converges to a normal zero when in
variable is the sample size
n goes to infinity and uh
the we're of course making the
assumption here
that we have a a good way of
constructing a
estimate of the asymptotic variance of
this estimator here
now we will note that uh the asymptotic
variance that we're trying to compute
the sigma squared involves the variance
of the gradient of g evaluated at the
expected valency
with z minus expected value
of z this thing
so this variance is going to involve the
covariances
the covariance structure of this random
vector and it's going to involve the
gradient
so these are both somewhat complex
quantities to estimate uh
in a or to compute in
at least some applications and as a
consequence
uh this is the first of the settings
that we will see
in which uh you might want to avoid
having to construct an estimated to
explicitly
estimate this variance and we will come
back to uh
simulation-based methods that allow one
to
avoid having to try to estimate this
very
messy variance quantity that arises in
the smooth function context
so here's an application uh we want to
compute the expected infinite horizon
discounted reward corresponding to a
markov chain
x r's reward function uh e to the minus
alpha i of the discount factor
and um of course this markov chain if we
start
off at some state x eventually we'll
come back to this state
x we'll take tau of x steps for that to
occur
and once we get back to this point
things effectively regenerate and as a
consequence
this quantity alpha can be
written in the following way we have
the expected reward up to the time that
we
come back to the state x plus everything
that
is earned from the hitting time of x and
onwards is discounted down by this
common factor
and once we're back at the state x
itself the system regenerates so the
expected reward from that time onwards
is just
the same alpha that we had initially and
let's consequently get this identity for
the quantity
alpha that means that we can estimate
this infinite horizon discounted reward
which by the way is not something that
can be
[Music]
easily simulated without a trick of some
kind because of course
this infinite sum involves the infinite
horizon behavior of the markov chain and
principle to actually generate this
random variable would take
infinite time i'd have to generate the
markov chain's trajectory
all the way out to infinity
so replace this non-simulatable quantity
by something that can be simulated
involving finite horizon quantities and
in particular
if we take this identity we can write
alpha as the expected value
of the discounted sum of the rewards
up to the return time to state x divided
by 1 minus
the expected value of the
discounted hitting time talent x
this is something that in turn can be
written as a smooth function
g of this expected value and this
expected value particularly the g
function in this case is just z1 divided
by one minus z2 it's just a
simple illustration of that smooth
function model on some settings we're
interested
in uh
doing steady state simulations we're
interested in equilibrium
quantities um so
in particular imagine that pi is the
equilibrium distribution
of the steady state distribution of the
markov chain
and we want to integrate some reward
function against the equilibrium
distribution we want to compute the
expected
reward associated with steady state
let's call x infinity
uh a random variable having the
equilibrium or steady state distribution
of the markov chain
the natural way to do that is to run the
markov chain for a long number of time
steps and look at the average reward
over that long
time horizon the so-called time average
that time average and grade generality
will converge with probability one to
alpha that's
a consequence of a law of large numbers
for markov chains
there's also going to be a central limit
theorem in great generality for that
time average
but the uh challenge now comes in trying
to
estimate this variance constant sigma
and
the difficulty comes about as a
consequence of the fact that these r of
x eyes are correlated
this is a consequence the variance sigma
squared
is something that involves this nasty
infinite sum involving covariances of
the rewards
uh taking j time steps apart so to make
sure that
the j's term involves over infinite r of
x zero and r of x j
we're looking at rewards making j time
steps apart we have to sum up all of
those covariances
so that time average variance constant
sigma squared is a nasty
object to try to estimate
any so there are lots of different
simulation settings and experiences are
hard to estimate
uh smooth functions of expectations
we've talked about that steady state
simulation
stochastic gradient descent turns out to
be another one quantiles
yet another many different simulation
settings in which
it's hard to estimate variances
therefore hard to construct confidence
intervals
can i interrupt you just for a second uh
so you were talking about
smooth functions and and
we had a talk earlier this week where
uh we were told about non-regular
inference and what happens when
g is non-smooth you get all sorts of
weird behaviors the
limiting distribution can abruptly
change under very minor perturbation
system
so i was wondering if the stochastic
simulation community has thought about
problems where g is non-smooth maybe g
is like this famous problem apparently
called max of means where g is just the
component wise max
there's some work in statistics on that
i was wondering if you had any thoughts
on that
did you use non-spoon there's a lot of
settings where you have that type of
issue coming up uh and there are
special purpose methods that people have
created for specific types of problems
i'm going to give you a general tool in
a couple of slides
that addresses that issue to some degree
oh great thanks so
uh let me first of all uh talk about
a setting that deals successfully
with the smooth function setting
there is one clarification question
before we move on to something else um
on
slide 17
some confusion as to why uh z bar
n became z z bar yeah
um
uh so is it at this point why
why is it why i have an expected value
of z sitting in here or what
uh i think the last line
we have z bar minus expectation of
z where you were pointing at and the
very last line
in expression for sigma squared
you have z no z bar n
uh right so that's because
um it is the case that the
quantity alpha n has a variance that
looks like sigma squared divided by n
but i've in the way i've written this
limit theorem the
one over n is already captured in the
scaling square root of n
so this this is basically the variance
per observation at some
level right so there should be no n in
this quantity
yeah basically taking a square of the
previous expression taking expectation
and uh identical distributions expensive
right and the scaling yeah exactly yeah
thank you
okay so uh let me come back to this
replication method
so this is a method that can be used
in lots of settings in which you know
that there's a limit theorem in which
the uh limit random variable
is normally distributed with mean zero
and potentially some complicated
covariance structure or variance
structure
so again the key thing is the right hand
side
is normal with mean zero
so if you have that then uh here's one
thing you can do you just take your
algorithm
and run the whole algorithm let's say m
iid times so these are the
replications and then
each of these replicated estimators
uh satisfies this limit theorem
which means of course that for large
values n
uh the estimator alpha and i coming from
replicating the
algorithm uh uh on the
on the ith iteration that's
approximately like a
independent normal with a mean equal to
the parameter that we're trying to
compute
and with a variance that is the variance
associated with this particular limit
theorem which
again if you square both sides and you
assume that the variance of the left
hand side converges a variance of the
right-hand side
it would that would be telling us that
the variance of alpha n looks
approximately like sigma squared and
divided by a squared
m for large values of n
so uh that means that uh
even if you only replicate this
algorithm twice you'll have
two of these different alpha and i's
these alpha and i's will look
approximately normal with
mean equal to the quantity that we're
trying to estimate
and with unknown variance and of course
statisticians
have a nice solution have a nice
answer to how you construct confidence
intervals when you have
unknown mean and unknown variance that
takes you into the world of student t
confidence intervals and so now all you
need to do in this context is just apply
that methodology we have unknown mean
alpha and known varium sigma squared
over a squared of n
just apply that standard statistics
methodology in this context
uh and uh there you have now a
confidence interval to deal with this
setting you never
uh this procedure avoids
having to explicitly try to estimate the
variance parameter
signal squared
right now there's another approach which
uh can be used in settings where the
right hand side is not
normal with mean zero and
uh some potentially complicated variants
and this is
to use the method of subsampling which
was developed
actually fairly recently in the last 20
years or so
by joe romano and company so
here's the way some sampling works so
suppose that you now have a monte carlo
algorithm in which
we know that this type of limit theorem
holds so there's some value of a and a
typical monte carlo algorithm
a would be equal to a half so you'd have
square root of scaling but it doesn't
have to be square rooted scaling
and n to the a times alpha n minus alpha
converges to w
so uh if a is positive this is saying
that
the error is shrinking
[Music]
at rate n to the minus a and
uh that w can be a very complicated
random variable we don't need to even
know
exactly what its distribution is it can
include music's parameters
all kinds of nasty things now the point
is that
if we choose a subsample m that's
significantly smaller than n
then we know that uh if
m is large but not as large as n and m
to the a times
alpha n minus alpha should be
approximately distributed as the random
variable w
that's according to this limit theorem
up here
uh we don't know alpha in general but we
if if m is much smaller than n then
alpha n has a precision that is so much
higher than the position of alpha and
itself that we can effectively you can
substitute alpha
m for alpha and get something that has
approximately the same distribution
now the thing that's nice about this is
this is something that is
computable and constructible so in
particular
if we now just construct multiple sub
samples of size
m from our end sample and we just
collect an empirical distribution of
these quantities
this empirical distribution should be
roughly the empirical distribution of w
from this empirical distribution we can
now select a w
and w two such that the probability
of coverage within that interval w one
to w two will be
approximately uh let's say ninety
percent
and now we just plug in that w one and w
two into the
original sample size and we get a
legitimate confidence bound
for the uh for this monophyletic
algorithm
there's a modic parallel procedure for
getting confidence intervals in settings
where
uh estimating variances
hired and maybe even the entire limit
distribution w
is close to intractable as you may
have seen uh earlier today or maybe
earlier in the week
uh there are a number of settings in the
world of stochastic optimization
where the limit random verbals double
you can be non gaussian be quite
complicated
this is potentially something that can
be used in those settings
then the last thing that i want to just
say before we finish this first lecture
is that uh many of us these days are
thinking about
trying to do computations in massively
parallel computing environments
and uh one thing to be aware of
is that uh there can be sometimes
significant challenges that arise in the
moderate harlow context
uh due to uh
completion time issues so let me just
say a little bit about that
so suppose that i want to estimate the
mean of a random verbal w and let's
suppose that
uh the random variable is simulatable so
i can run iid replications
on different parallel processes so
imagine a large number of p so parallel
processors available
i'm going to run for c units of computer
time on all p
processors now one thing that you might
think about doing is i
will uh average the number of
completed replications on each of the
p processors and form a sample average w
bar ifc here the random variable
nifc is the random number of uh
replications of w that is able to
successfully complete
on the i processor within computer time
c
and then of course we can just average
over the p
processes then we get the expected value
of w
bar c plus a
a normal uh
error that decreases at range 1 over
square root of p
times c 1 over square root of p times c
because of course the total amount of
sampling time available
is all you have p processors you
[Music]
have computer times c available on each
of the p processors so total amount of
computer time
utilized over all p processors is p
times c and we have a squared
convergence rate
so we should have this thing scaling
down at rate 1 over square root of pc
but now we have to look at this quantity
here
and we can see that if the number of
processes p is large
uh it could be that this bias
this thing expected that w bar c is not
exactly
equal to the quantity that we're trying
to compute
so when p is large maybe that what
you're
computing what you're uh by averaging
all these different quantities
is something that is dominated by the
bias dominated by how far away this
expected value is from the true thing
that you're trying to compute
and this bias issue that arises because
of the fact that
uh w bars c is as
uh as a biased estimator uh can
have uh consideration can complicate
the uh the analysis in these types of
massively parallel computing
environments
there are different types of fixes that
are available and that's something that
i looked at in a bunch of papers with
phil heidelberger from ibm
back in the 1990s that might be relevant
in the current context and current times
as well
all right so that's the end of my first
lecture in the second lecture i'll talk
about variance reduction
and gradient estimation so thank you
so we'll be back i guess at uh two
o'clock
thanks peter there is one follow-up
question that came which was about
uh constructing the confidence intervals
for the sub-sampling section
um could you give more detail as to how
we would actually
uh learn or use the estimates to
construct the confidence interval
or just taking the quantiles or
so uh right so so the key
issue here is constructing these
sub-sample functions
now in some settings it won't be hard to
do that so for example with the context
of the smooth function
model if i wanted to use subsampling
that context
and i don't think that would be the
right thing to do in that setting i
think what you would do
in the smooth function setting is you
would
use the replication method potentially
for something like that
but if you wanted to apply sub-sampling
you do
have to construct uh the estimator's
alpha m from the um
you know corresponding to a sub-sample
of size m now it could be you know that
that
you just run uh you know just take
whatever algorithm that you had
initially and you re-initialize that
algorithm and you know run it with
independent random numbers that gives
you an alpha m and you do that a bunch
of times
that gives you the are different
subsample quantities you might be
thinking to yourself well that seems
uh extremely inefficient and it is
beneficial that's why you wouldn't use
sub sampling unless this is basically a
last resort to the situation
but uh you know in in some contexts
the uh the
computational complexity required to
compute alpha m as a function of the
number of samples
m taken scales non-linearly
in the sample size so
uh you know the the it might be for
example
in an optimization context it could be
for various reasons that
uh the complexity of computing alpha
m doesn't grow linearly in m and
then uh computing alpha m
for relatively small values of m as
compared to n
could be a fairly small computational
overhead relative to computing alpha in
itself
so having to do these sort of
independently generate a whole bunch of
alpha m's corresponding much smaller
sample sizes in the end that we use for
the sort of grand estimate itself
could be something that would be
[Music]
practically viable
and and just to clarify in case people
are getting confused this w is just
is just a placeholder here it's not the
same w that we started the talk with
whose expectation is
alpha right like there's no reason why
this limit will be this
thank you very much yes sorry for
confusing you if i confused
any of you by using the same yes it's a
completely
distinct random quantity thank you
so much you know one setting where i've
seen this come up myself is in settings
for example you do
random sampling within the let's say a
hypercube
to try to identify
the minimum of a function over the
hypercube
and where the function evaluations
involve
having to run simulations at the
different points in the hyper cube
in that context uh when you develop a
limit theorem for that type of estimator
the
the right hand side actually turns out
to be quite a messy
object not something that you'd want to
to work with and it would be an object
that has lots of messy nuisance
parameters in it as well
so it's not like the normal distribution
where the nuisance parameters are a
scale and location parameter you can
easily deal with them as a consequence
of that
uh scaling location focus but the usage
parameters that arise in that
in the limit theorem for that the type
of uh
algorithm that i just described was a
entered a very very messy way
and then you said earlier that getting
information a priory about let's say the
bounds of the random variable this is
hard in in typical situations it's this
type of information is either not
available or if you give some very
large bounds then the confidence
intervals you'll get will be
uninformative did i interpret you
correctly i think that's correct
and for example in the markov chain
context
uh you know if you want to uh
get an apriori bound for example on the
[Music]
this time average variance function on
this sigma squared
this would be very very you know you
could do it there are
uh mathematical methods available
to uh bound the sigma squared
in the markov chain context
but uh i think it's fair to say that
the uh downs you would get
in a typical application would be
probably close to unusable
oh sorry and one more clarifying
question before i guess we take a break
um would you mind going to slide 18
please
questions about how you got alpha on the
right hand side
in the final formula right so
uh this maybe
becomes clearer if you just write this
infinite sum
as uh as some of the
discounted rewards up to the return time
to the state
x so that would be a sum
of uh like this
so that's um and then
i have the sum from 12x to infinity
i'm going to write this by
uh factoring out the common discount
factor
so this thing would have either minus
alpha j up here but all of the j's
that are sitting up here have j greater
equal to tau of x i can write this
as also as k plus tau
x where now k is ranging from
k equals zero to infinity
i'm just doing a
rewriting this piece and now i'd have
rewards
that involve the post power of x markov
chain
that would involve the path of markup
chain beyond tan tau of x
and then i'm just using a strong markov
property to say that
e to the minus alpha tau of x is
independent of the
uh random variables in this sub so i'm
writing this as eta minus power
x in summation k equals to infinity of e
to the minus alpha i
times r of x x plus
i this quantity here has exactly the
same distribution
as this random variable conditional and
having come back
to the initial state a second time
and strong markov property says that
these two random variables are
independent
so the expected value of the product is
the product of expected values and we
get this
piece
thank you that makes a lot of sense um
would you be
yeah sorry java yeah sorry uh
just for the same slide so also appears
both in the exponent and both uh
the definition of this aspect that's a
bad uh
we could see here
i think that it was that was maybe what
uh led to the question
i think that's a very good
uh it's an unfortunate use of notation
in my head
yeah different communities
different symbols
well in any community you don't want to
have alpha being two different things on
the same slide so
yeah mistaken like
would it be possible to get these slides
and also the slides from
part two so you can follow along yep
absolutely
perfect that'll be really helpful
i don't see any more questions
last chance for anyone
otherwise thank you peter i think we
resume
at two o'clock great thank you